[Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  hey pop sensation BTS made their US  television debut and became the first  Korean boyband to perform at the  American Music Awards it is BTS mania at  the American Music Awards fans lined up  look at the cameras behind you how are  you guys feeling  it's great ET was with the guys  backstage just after their electrifying  performance of DNA  [Music]  don't get my  you guys killed it on the choreography  you guys made history tonight at the  AMAs how do you feel yeah it was  wonderful you know it was a dream what  was it like to be on the AMA stage um  you know it's like there were like  millions of people standing and fans  were screaming and you know like oh you  know that world celebrate is in front of  us still I cannot maybe I think we  cannot forget it like for a life  lifelong if a lifelong pitcher yeah  [Music]  you